[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
le secrétaire d'état à la ruralité
bonjour je vais lui dire bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
julien lécuyer de la voix du nord
bonjour julien bonjour oriane bonjour
bonjour et on commence bien sûr par la
crise sanitaire et jean castex qui est
donc attendu ce soir à 18h10
départements sont dans une situation
difficile c'est ce que dit gabriela
talent après nice et dunkerque y
aura-t-il de nouvelles annonces de
confinement locaux ce soir très
franchement je l'ignorent l'instant je
vous parle ce que je pense c'est
qu'effectivement on est arrivé une
certaine territorialisation de la crise
qui était pas possible dans certaines
circonstances vous rappeler au moment de
la crise des stations de ski
il y avait déjà des voix qui s'étaient
élevées pour proposer
déterritorialisation mais là ça devenait
difficile parce que vous êtes sur un
outil que de musique ou un jour vous
allez prendre des mesures sur un
département le lendemain sur le
département voisin en fait je sais
c'était quelque chose qui était
rigoureusement impossible pour la
gestion de l'économie
dès lors qu'il ya des poches qui
deviennent des poches de pandémie qui
sont difficiles à gérer la
territorialisation semble quand même la
voie la plus la plus intéressante alors
pas forcément sur le temps durs
confinement mais peut-être sur ton de
mesures complémentaires et nécessaires
ne serait ce que pour aussi certains
départements qui sont des départements
frontaliers ou sans cela on va avoir une
une difficulté notamment en matière de
droits des travailleurs transfrontaliers
qui vont passer la frontière il faut
quand même montré un certain nombre de
six mesures complémentaires comme comme
quoi il ya le couvre-feu élargie qui à
quoi vous pensez par exemple
bon bah c'est surtout j'allais dire sur
la façon de
ce qui s'est passé a dit c'est à dire en
fait on est dans des situations où un
certain nombre de magasins de temps de
mètres carrés doivent ne doivent plus
ouvrir dans ce qu'il y à des
concentrations importantes de personnes
voilà c'est une situation qui est qui
est assez difficile à gérer mais qui qui
viennent sur nécessité parler les
événements récents en matière de demande
et donc pour vous les dix départements
qui se moque-t-on le taux d'incidence le
plus élevé doivent s'attendre à avoir
des mesures complémentaires dans les
prochains jours des mesures plus
restrictives qui me semble évidente même
s'il ne s'agit pas de confinement de
confinement mais des mesures plus
restrictives
oui je pense que on est dans cette
situation si c'était pas le curseur de
la culture ce n'est pas dit s'il peut
être à 5 mais bon on est sur des
logiques sont des logiques j'allais lire
de renforcement de mesures pour éviter
que nous ayons une nouvelle flambée de
ce virus le gouvernement le gouvernement
joue la carte de la territorialisation
mais de plus en plus de voix s'élèvent
quand même pour dire notamment du côté
scientifique pour dire que on est en
train de perdre du temps je reprend une
phrase dax et le cac de généticiens qui
vient de qui vient de s'exprimer qui dit
prendre une décision réfléchie contre
l'avis majoritaire ça s'appelle de
l'audace c'est ce qu'a fait emmanuel
macron s'y tenir lorsque les paramètres
indique qu'elle n'est pas bonne et de
l'entêtement et tout ce que moi je fais
moi je veux bien quand on écoute au long
d'une décision qui est prise à partir
d'un certain nombre de paramètres
je regarde ce qui se passe aussi chez
les oiseaux c'est moi je suis frontalier
de l'italie il ya un taux qui est un
taux d'incidence qui est plus faible
qu'en france à l'heure actuelle alors
que c'est on va dire qu'il ya beaucoup
de zones sa vie une territorialisation
qui est totale ne serait ce que parce
qu'aussi la santé et territoriales en
italie c'est à dire que les décisions ne
sont jamais des décisions du ministère
de la santé met souvent de décision des
autorités régionales de de santé je
constate que les crises sont dirigés de
manière différente parce qu'il ya une
acceptabilité qui est différente aussi
suivant les pays
en italie il n'y
pas eu de confinement de la zone
piémontaise
qui est qui et ma voisine il y à un taux
d'incidence est un taux de nombre de
malades qui est relativement faible
pour autant les derniers indicateurs
redevenez à nouveau mauvais alors qu'on
était dans une situation qui était
plutôt bonne il y à quelques temps voilà
donc jeu très franchement je crois que
beaucoup de jeux en fait personne ne
sait vraiment comment fonctionne ce
virus et on peut écouter effectivement
tous les scientifiques il ya des
scientifiques qui disent une chose et
scientifiques qui disent une chose
quelquefois légèrement différente des
autres
je crois qu'il appartient au président
de la république de prendre des mesures
justes que vous avez des données en de
circulation de ce virus est ce que même
dans ces zones touchées le virus circule
autant dans les zones urbaines que dans
les zones rurales où est ce que la
ruralité est plutôt épargné par ce virus
la ruralité n'est pas forcément épargné
regardez au tout début de la de la
deuxième vague de la pandémie
j'habite dans le département des
hautes-alpes qui a eu pendant dix jours
le taux d'incidence le plus élevé la
ruralité chez nous il n'ya que ça je
veux dire les espaces ouverts absolument
incroyable et il fallait d'ailleurs
demandé aux touristes qui venaient au
week-end de penser à mettre leurs
masques dans l'est dans les commerces
parce qu'il était persuadé qu étant au
grand air il ne se passerait rien alors
que les taux d'incidence est s upérieure
à marca qu'à marseille qui est quand
même une très grande il donc ces raisons
prochaine le fais moi je crois qu'on est
sur un virus ou le fonctionnement des
packs complètement connu c'est évident
et qu'il y a de temps en temps des
facteurs externes qui font que alors ici
c'est l'ouverture de maisons à caractère
sanitaire et social et la scolarisation
se lancer ce qui nous est arrivé dans la
région de briançon gérer brutalement la
c est une reine autre facteur donc faire
du cousu main en évitant quelque chose
qui est psychologique ans de plus en
plus difficile leur confinement me
semble une mesure 6 ou si vous parlez
cousu main c'est peut-être très bien
mais on parle plus de cousu main dans le
sens restrictif mais pas dans le sens
permissif il ya de plus en plus d'appels
de maires de petites communes où le
virus circule peu qu'ils disent mais
nous on n'est pas touché pourquoi on
devrait laisser nos commerces fermés ne
pas ouvrir les terrasses c'est le cas
dans le
dans le final par exemple la wii ou une
manière générale
exactement je peux être pour éviter
aussi qu'il y est par effet de
correction fait la france n'est pas un
pays où les frontières soient aussi
marqué que cela surtout les frontières
intérieures j'allais dire donc peut-être
pour éviter notamment qu'en cette
période où il ya encore des congés
scolaires je vous le rappelle oui
qu'il y ait j'allais dire
des mesures qui soient trop lâche dans
un certain nombre de départements où il
ya un certain nombre de touristes qui
viennent d'un peu partout
vous savez j'étais chez moi ce week-end
j'ai été frappé par la densité de
touristes dans un certain nombre de
stations il y avait des stations y avait
personne y avait d'autres stations il y
avait énormément de monde
voilà donc d'une commune à l'autre on a
des facteurs tels que c'est difficile je
crois de prendre des mesures qui
seraient des mesures plus favorable dans
des endroits où l'on croit que la
situation peut être extrêmement des
remontées mécaniques elle n'a pas eu
l'impact espéré pour les stations de ski
en termes de triage de la circulation du
virus
il ya quand même moins de monde il ya
quand même moins de monde et il n'y a
pas de concentration sur un certain
nombre de sujets en revanche il y a
quand même du monde ya des gens qui sont
venus en vacances je dis toujours avec
ce même esprit papa trop peut pas dire
trop c'est ça on va pas dire aux gens
resteraient niveau liberté mais il ya
simplement des gens qui viennent en
vacances avec un esprit qui est je vous
le dis on est au grand air donc tout va
bien se passer et c'est pas comme ça que
ça marche la circulation de ce virus
soit là donc être prudent en étant moins
plus restrictives dans les endroits où
il ya vraiment des difficultés et en ne
lâchant pas la bride sur les endroits où
il y en a où il y en a - ou peu me
semble une bonne politique voilà un mot
sur le vaccin sur le vaccin
oui messieurs reste lui dans l'est dans
les territoires ruraux en l'occurrence
les élus dénoncer encore fin janvier les
dysfonctionnements au delà de la
campagne
ils demandaient une plus grande
transparence des déremboursements pour
ce qui concerne le personnel engagé ou
bien la location de salles n'étaient
plein de disparité est ce que vous avez
résolu ces dysfonctionnements écoutez il
ya aussi des secteurs dans la ruralité
où ça se passe plutôt bien où je veux
j'arrive d'un des voyages officiels dans
le haut var j'ai vu des médecins
retraités qui ne demandaient absolument
rien des sapeurs pompiers étaient
mobilisés comme si on était mobilisée
j'allais dire prends un grand incendie
de forêt qui qui menace un village et
tout le monde était solidaire il n'y
avait pas de revendication particulière
et jeune homme difficile la vaccination
dans les zones rurales ou pas et c'est
dans le diffus c'est forcément plus vous
savez c'est un petit peu comme tout je
fais souvent la comparaison avec les
maisons france service savait comment
qu'on mène quelquefois c'est plus facile
d'avoir toutes les informations dans une
maison france service dans la ruralité
que de la voir dans une grande ville
hélas en l'espèce j'ai posé la question
j'étais à aups qui était un endroit
quand même assez isolée sur le sur le
sur le plan routier sur le pro
ferroviaire encore plus j'allais dire eh
bien je voyais des gens qui venaient du
lavandou parce qu'ils n'avaient plus
confiance de venir dans l'arrière-pays
voir des gens qui les recevait avec
j'allais dire beaucoup de mots beaucoup
de gentillesse des bénévoles ils
venaient se faire vacciner
du côté d'aups
j'ai mis des gens qui étaient tous moi
je vais médecin qui a repris du service
tout cela a été géré de manière assez
familial et sympathique
voilà un autre bus j'ai vu un autre bus
je prenais devant tout va bien on va
dire que toujours tout va bien parce que
ça n'a pas de sens mais j'ai vu aussi un
bus france service désaffectée pour
faire justement de la vaccination dans
des zones rurales pour que les gens qui
ne peuvent pas se déplacer puisse y
aller donc je crois franchement qui a
une situation qui est maîtrisée lors y
aura toujours un couac de ci de là parce
qu'une journée territorialement moins
couvertes parce qu'on n'a pas trouvé les
les médecins qu'elle une fois la
retraite d'ailleurs pour venir sur le
secteur mais mais globalement je pense
qu une situation qui est maîtrisée qui
en tout état de cause n'est pas atypique
là encore je vous dis mon jeu je suis un
vrai frontaliers donc jaillir suprascan
binational je vois ce qui se passe de
part et d'autre de la frontière je n'ai
pas le sentiment qu'il y ait sur ce plan
là de grandes divergences et de grandes
différences quand je suis dans la zone
de montagne du piémont que je suis dans
les zones de montagne les hautes-alpes
dernière question sur ce sujet oui
l'association des petites villes de
france a écrit un courrier à la ministre
de la culture ça rejoint un peu notre
discussion on lui de demander
d'autoriser la réouverture d'aider
certains lieux culturels dans l'est dans
les petites villes
ça ça rejoint la question de la
préoccupation des gens qui ne
comprennent pas comment on peut aller
dans les dents les les supermarchés et
pas dans l'est pas dans les musées
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez écouter
moi j'ai senti faible pour être clair de
pas aller dans un supermarché ça veut
dire ne plus aller dans des endroits on
peut s'alimenter aussi ça veut pas dire
que les gens refusaient d'aller dans les
musées parce que pendant pour écouter en
on a des thés des territoires où vous
avez dans le musée des concentrations de
personnes qui sont extrêmement
importantes et c'est peut-être aussi
parce que lorsqu'on est dans un musée on
fait moins attention que dans un
supermarché où tout le monde se met son
match je me limite et même en prenant
rendez-vous s'est hissé en tête des pays
où vous savez bien sûr là on peut
toujours comparer tout le monde et on en
arrive après au restaurant se disant
mais pourquoi c'est ouvert en italie à
midi pourquoi c'est pas ouverts en
france voilà il ya aussi des pays je
vais être franc il ya des pays où les
protocoles sont respectés vraiment au
pied de la lettre et coûtait pas
toujours jeu je vais être franc jeu
lorsque je vais là aussi le côté de la
frontière excusez moi de prendre
toujours des points de repères mais je
suis obligé quand je viens à paris je
passe deux fois la frontière franco
italienne
je constate simplement que même quand
vous allez aux toilettes dans une
dans un restaurant à midi eh bien on
vous suit on nettoie l'intégralité des
toilettes à chaque passage les
protocoles sont parfois beaucoup plus
strictes et beaucoup plus respectés côté
caennais voilà c'est une once à des prix
ronds pour écouter ils étaient ouverts
entre je vous fais des comparaisons qui
sont des comparaisons aussi de cet été
c'était très différent des deux côtés de
la frontière
est-ce que c'est aussi parce que on d'un
côté on a vu beaucoup plus peur de ce
qui s'est passé sur la première phase de
la pandémie ça peut être ça aussi parce
que psychologiquement ça vous marque on
va parler d'agriculture 0 emmanuel
macron qui était en déplacement en
côte-d'or à la rencontre des
agriculteurs puisque le salon d'agréger
sur n'a pas lieu cette année
l'agriculture qui reste quand même
colonne vertébrale de la réalité mais
les agriculteurs ils ont du mal à vivre
du fruit de leur travail est ce que
l'état ait suffisamment à l'école assez
à leurs côtés comment on peut les aider
comment ces agriculteurs on peut leur
dire mais oui vous allez réussir à vivre
du fruit de votre travail je crois déjà
comment plus faute clair la loi et gally
mais a quand même posé les bases d'un
nouveau système bon un nouveau système
dans un monde qui est complexe ça se met
pas en place en 24 heures ou en un an ou
en deux ans parce que je viens poser les
bases de ce nouveau système
est-ce qu'il faut les revoir ses bad
dont je pense que je pense que le
système tel qu'il est posé avec des
rencontres qui sont des rencontres quasi
permanente entre le miz de l'agriculture
et la ministre à des espagnols une hache
et chargé jantes et des entreprises fait
qu' il y ait un dialogue qui s'est
instauré un dialogue qui n'est pas nous
fallait et qui porte ses fruits sur un
certain nombre de choses regarder ce qui
s'est passé sur le prix du lait par
exemple près du lait c'est un bon
exemple de prix qui avaient pu être
soutenu et puis il y avait trop monté il
ya des filières où c'est beaucoup plus
difficile parce qu'on est dans un pays
qui a une culture ancienne mais moi ce
que je vois surtout c'est que lorsque je
raconte des ingrédients je compte
beaucoup de jia de jeunes agriculteurs
on est quand même sur des logiques et
qui sont de plus en plus différentes
aussi de leur côté c'est à dire qu'on
est sur des logiques moins productiviste
on est sur des logiques où justement le
plan de relance et est attendu pour
accompagner un certain nombre de mesures
territoriale puisque je suis plus de
1000 s'agit plus de mesures
territoriales qui m'intéresse que des
mesures je peux dire que les mesures
agricoles en tant que telle ne
m'intéresse pas mais
j'étais encore là encore en voyage
officiel en train de recevoir des jeunes
agriculteurs qui représentent l ensemble
de ceux de la région provence alpes côte
d'azur est ce que je constate
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils sont ils sont
sur des logiques de faisons en sorte que
le système de primes privilégie aussi
les petites exploitations et pas
forcément les très grandes exploitations
alors les exploitations que je peux je
qualifierais de 2 me salir ou des gens
font autre chose que de l'agriculture
parce que c'est bien ça le sujet et
pourquoi pas tout simplement pour faire
en sorte que l'on concentre un certain
nombre de moyens sur des secteurs qui
dans le secteur de circuits courts et
aux donc on est sur les bases mêmes de
la loi et galim et je constate
que ça fonctionne et que
les revendications qui sont les leurs
aujourd'hui moi je les accompagne plutôt
parce qu'on est sur des logiques de
circuits courts on est sur des logiques
d'abattoirs d'officialité est là elle a
permis un bond de ses circuits courts un
retour au local un retour à la terre est
ce que finalement il ya eu des points
positifs de cette crise sanitaire pour
l'aréna j'allais dire malheureusement
oui puisque mais il faut toujours dire
malheureusement parce que keith une
pandémie qui a des morses et les
chaussons sont difficiles mais on a très
honnêtement on s'est posé tous la
question de savoir où étaient les
approvisionnements et dans quelles
conditions on pouvait s'approvisionner
de manière correcte
moi je regardais fait il ya une mesure
qui fonctionne bien je trouve que ce
sont les programmes alimentaires
territoriaux où on est dans des logiques
j'ai d'ailleurs vu le premier ministre
lui disant qu'il fallait que l'on
mélange ces politiques là avec les
politiques de cowboy la cantine un euro
et autres pour qu'ils aient vraiment eu
nul logique j'irai 2 de la production
jusqu'à l'assiette du gamin qui est qui
dans une dans un secteur scolarisés où
il va la cantine et là on en a fait s'il
y avait de mieux à mon avis en terme de
deux contrats de réciprocité entre la
ville et la campagne
c'est un très bon exemple et s'il ya des
moyens là dessus 81 millions d'euros sur
l'épée à témoin ce que j'attends c'est
qu'on puisse vraiment les développer sur
des actions un pas que sur des
ingénieurs
l'option dans la nuit avant de parler de
la loi cadets avec julien comment on
fait pour que cette volonté de circuits
courts et de local elle perdure et
qu'une fois la crise sanitaire par ces
les français ne retrouvent pas leurs
habitudes d'aller dans les grandes
surfaces
qu'est ce que le gouvernement va faire
là encore je vous citais c'est pas par
hasard les programmes alimentaires
territoriaux je veux le faire on est en
été sur des logiques où il y avait de la
grille bashing en permanence là il ya
beaucoup d'argent qui est mise justement
sur ces circuits cure sur cpa t sur la
rénovation des abattoirs moi je suis un
fan des abattoirs de proximité
si vous savez on était sur des logiques
ou c'était bio double ça vienne contre
agriculture non raisonnée on est passé
quand même une autre logique on
l'accompagnent ça dans le plan de
relance de manière très très très
spectaculaire il ya 1,2 milliard sur sur
ces filières agricoles qui ne demande
qu'à être dépensée est ce que je vois
c'est là encore des gia des jeunes
agriculteurs qui sont en train de
regarder comment on peut mettre en
oeuvre sur des territoires ces
politiques là moi je les vois dans le
cadre du programme montagne bien
évidemment parce qu'on est en train de
l'élaborer mais ils sont ce sont les
mêmes que je rencontre un peu partout
jeudi je rencontre les gia dans
l'aveyron et dans l'aveyron ce qu'on me
dit c'est avant d'être agriculteur on
est jeune on vit sur un territoire et on
a besoin nous d'avoir un accompagnement
territoriales pour que notre association
ne meurt pas on est on est on est sur
des logiques bien différente aujourd'hui
j'en suis très content oui la loi cadre
qui doit réformer les relations entre
l'état et les territoires le projet de
loi cadre des a été transmis à la
semaine dernière au conseil des jeux là
il pourrait être présenté fin mars début
avril on est sur ce calendrier la poudre
en conseil des ministres on dit qu'il a
été sauvée des eaux in extremis puisque
il y avait faute de temps législatif
vous nous confirmer qu'il est revenue
par là par la petite porte au dernier
moment ce qui est clair c'est que sur le
calendrier initial c'était compliqué
vous le savez comme moi enfin venue des
arbitres il ya eu un arbitrage qui les
arbitrages jacqueline le goro moi même
on a été un certain nombre à peser en
faveur de ce projet de loi parce qu'il
nous semble indispensable
il ya des mesures qui sont dans bond
peut on peut toujours les découper par
appartement j'allais dire comme la vente
à la découpe et se dire je vais trouver
un véhicule législatif là là là mais il
ya eu quand même une cohérence à avoir
une étape complémentaire de la
décentralisation de la dea complique
filiation et la différenciation qui
était tentante
on vient de nommer un député qui est
jean pierre cubertafon pour s'occuper
justement de ces problèmes qui sont les
problèmes
différenciation territoriale par sur les
territoires ruraux parce que les
territoires ruraux c'est par essence des
choses complètement différents sons peut
pas comparer
le massif central le massif alpin les
plaines
de saintonge enfin voilà jeu et on a les
députés qui va excusez moi me suis
vraiment qualité qu'elle a quel a été
l'élément décisif pour pour pour le
maintenir au calendrier législatif
est-ce que c'est pas disons le aussi la
proximité des élections régionales et
départementales qui joue pour montrer
que dans ce cadre là l'état fait quand
même quelque chose pour trouver une
nouvelle relation avec les territoires
écoutez moi je sais ce qui a été
fondamental sur le maintien de ce texte
au calendrier
ça a été la pression des élus de tous
bords les élus locaux et les élus locaux
sont en attente de ce texte
moi à chaque fois j'avais les gens de
l'association des maires ruraux de
france qui misait mais quand c'est que
quand tu sais que ça va sortir parce
qu'on a des volontés d'amendements sans
dentelles sens aux dentelles sens aînés
ruraux mais l'association des maires de
france et quand même c'est quand même
une autre limonade
est ce que vous attendez à beaucoup de
positions de leur part bah écoutez moi
je vois plus les maires ruraux club mais
faut le comprendre et bien mais je
connais aussi des gens là mf qui voit
plutôt en dehors du contexte politique
tout cela d'un bon oeil
qu'ils disent pas forcément gérer un
geste politicien d'or de la part d'une
certaine certaines franges la mf qui
voilà qui qui est sur le refus un peu
total d'un certain nombre de choses je
le regarde d'ailleurs mais bon moi je
travaille avec des maires ruraux qui par
essence ont certes des opinions
politiques mais pensent à leur
territoire avant de penser aux grandes
organisations politiques eux on avait
besoin et nous nous avons besoin aussi
je donnerai un seul exemple qui mais qui
me semble intéressant on s'est aperçu
vous savez pour les problèmes de
médecins en zone rurale
on s'est aperçu qu'ils avaient des
expérimentations dans des départements
puy-de-dôme saône-et-loire
vous avez des espèces de dispensaires
départementaux qui ont été mis en place
pour combler ces les zones qui sont des
zones avec des petits trous j'ai bien
passé a pas de médecin eh bien ça on est
sur une expérimentation mais on a besoin
d'un cadre législatif
il est dans la loi cadre des voilà donc
vous avez un tas de gens qui attendent y
compris des départements que l'on puisse
avoir un cadre législatif pour des
actions qui jusqu'à présent étaient des
actions entre guillemets
légèrement en dehors du contexte
juridique français les dernières
questions bien oui ne simplement sur sur
les maisons françaises vis en janvier
2021 vous parliez de on avait installé
1123 maisons françaises labellisées
l'objectif était de 2001 10 2020-2022
fin 2022
est ce que vous tiendrez cet objectif
écoutez moi il me semble évident qu'on
va le tenir et donc au bout d'ailleurs
pour être sûr que quand on va les tenir
mais surtout qu'on va tenir la promesse
présidentielle qui était celle d'une
maison par canton mais enfin une maison
a maintenant deux minutes voilà s'il ya
peut-être des zones où justement c'est
c'est mieux développer que d'autres moi
je viens des départements où on a mis en
place des maisons de service public
depuis les années 1990
donc bon évidemment c'est facile de les
labelliser puisque on a déjà des gens
qui font quelquefois plus que même le
bouquet obligatoire que l'on impose
maintenant il ya d'autres endroits où
les maisons de services yayi sont
arrivés uniquement via le biais de la
poste des agences postales où il n'y
avait rien d'autre donc on est en train
de travailler j'ai eu à ce titre
l'ancien député jean launay qui est
chargé d'une mission sur ce sujet pour
que justement puisse faire coïncider la
carte géographique des maisons france
service avec la réalité jaillir du
territoire et qu'on regarde là où il y a
des trous dans la raquette
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde
s'est mis au tennis tout le monde doit
avoir un tennis elbow sur le sur le
coude mais surtout sur la raquette et
rue de la carte de france voir les
endroits où effectivement il faut donner
un coup de boost pour qu'il n'y ait pas
de de disparités entre certains
départements voilà c'est moi c'est ça ma
préoccupation essentielle au delà du
nombre et au delà du chiffre c'est que
la promesse présidentielle soit soient
respectées sur le maillage territorial
fin et on regarde rapidement une vidéo
avant de se quitter je crois que c'est
une nouvelle façon de communiquer pour
vous c'est ça de musclor connaître vos
actions
si on n'a pas de réseau pas de bonnes
connexions mais il n'empêche le teacch
écoutez vous ferez comme gabriel attal
non mais problème pour l'instant c'est
beaucoup plus rural non c'est c'est eh
c'est amusant parce que c'est un clin
d'oeil qui nous est venue après le débat
justement au sénat sur le patrimoine
sensorielle des campagnes on s'est dit
après tout pourquoi pas alors je précise
une chose le ministre est celui qui
parle est celui qui chante c'est le
coquen ses jambes
merci j'ai regardé la voix du nord c'est
évidemment dunkerque à la une de la voix
du nord
hélas ce wiki fait kiffer l'actuel on
espère que ça va s'arranger
le dunkerque par confiner le week-end
merci beaucoup merci d'être venus et en
face au club et à la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés dans
la transition zéro carbone des régions
vous présente le club des territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidien